welcome to cs224n lecture 15. so i'm
megan and i'm one of the cities in this
course and i'm also a phd student
working with chris ray
and today i'll be talking about
integrating knowledge and language
models
so some quick reminders your project
milestones were due today so hopefully
you turn those in already or we'll be
turning them in the next couple of days
and we'll try to get feedback on those
as fast as possible
so something to be aware of is a change
of grading basis and course withdrawal
deadline is this friday
um so if you want to make any change
your grade make sure to do that by then
and we'll be getting you the grades back
on assignment five by then as well in
case that's helpful in making your
decision
and finally your final projects are due
in two weeks so hopefully those are
going smoothly
so the topic of the day is integrating
knowledge and language models you've
seen a bit about this idea in assignment
five and also in colin raffle's lecture
last class so in assignment 5 the task
was to train a model to predict the
birthplace of a person given their name
and you saw it by pre-training on a
larger data set you're actually able to
do better on this task since you could
encode some world knowledge into the
language model
and then last lecture colin raffle
presented how t5 could actually be
fine-tuned for a closed domain question
answering task such that you can give
t5 a natural language question and it'll
return an answer
so they will be building on these
threads and looking at techniques that
researchers have recently been
developing to increase the amount of
knowledge in language models
so we're going to start with a quick
recap of language models just to make
sure we're all on the same page
then we're going to talk about what
types of knowledge language models can
already encode and what they might
struggle on
we'll also motivate why researchers are
interested in increasing the amount of
knowledge in language models and what
this could enable for future ai systems
if we have language models that can
actually reliably recall knowledge
we'll talk about three broad classes of
techniques that researchers have been
using to add knowledge to language
models these include adding pre-trained
entity embeddings using external memory
or key value store or even just
modifying the training data
and for each of these techniques we'll
talk about at least one recent work that
used the technique so hopefully it's
clear to see how to actually employ it
in practice
and then finally we'll wrap up by
talking about how to evaluate the
knowledge in language models and the
challenges that come up in trying to do
this
so let's dive right in
we're going to start by talking about
standard language models you learned
about these at the beginning of the
course and the task is to predict the
next word and sequence of text and to
compute the probability of a sequence so
you may remember the example that
students opened their blank and we
talked about could be minds exams bring
both books here
and the task of the standard language
model is to predict the most likely next
word in the sequence
a couple lectures ago john also
introduced the notion of mass language
models instead of predicting the next
word in a sequence of text the tasks
predict the mass token
and this is done using bi-directional
context
so you may remember the example i masked
the mask and the goal the mass language
model is to make the most likely token
for each of the masked out words
so maybe i went to the store
so while there's some differences in
these two types of language models
whether you're predicting the next word
or whether you're predicting the massdot
token
they're similar and that they can both
be trained over large amounts of
unlabeled text
and this is one of the reasons why
they've been so widely adopted they
don't require any human annotated data
so you've seen that language models can
be used for a variety of tasks from
summarization to dialogue to fluency
evaluation
tasks that involve either generating
text or evaluating the probability of
text
and more recently we've seen that
language models can also be used to
generate pre-changed representations of
text that encodes some notion of
language understanding and has been
shown to be widely useful for different
downstream nlp tasks
and then finally today we're going to
touch on this idea that if language
models are trained over massive amounts
of text can they even be used as a
knowledge base
so we're going to start by looking at
what types of factual knowledge a
language model might already know
and these examples are taken from a
paper by petroni at all
in emlp a couple years ago and the goal
is to test the factual or common sense
knowledge in existing language models
such as bert large
so let's check out what bert large
predicts
ipod touch is produced by apple london
jazz festival is located in london
uh danny alves plays with santos carl
iii used to communicate in german and
ravens can fly
so here we have the correct predictions
in green and the incorrect predictions
in red
and if you know anything about sports
you may know that danny alves is a
soccer player santos is a soccer team
here they were hoping that it would
predict barcelona because at least at
the time of this data set apparently he
played for barcelona and carl iii
actually used to communicate in swedish
not german
so what's good about these examples
is the predictions are generally
reasonable if you didn't know the ground
truth
they all make sense when you want to
produce a when you want to predict a
language you do in fact predict a
language
but of course they're not all factually
correct
so why might this happen
well for one the fact might not been
seen in training and you can't expect
the language model to do more than
recall facts that it has seen in
training it can't make up facts about
the world for instance
it's also possible the fact is just
really rare so maybe the language model
has seen the factoring training but it
hasn't seen it enough times actually
memorize the fact
and the last issue is a little more
subtle
which a model might just be very
sensitive to the phrasing of the fill in
the blank statement
and so for example you might have
statements like x was created in blank
that the model can't predict correctly
but if you change it to x was made in
blank suddenly it can predict it
correctly and we'll come back to this in
how to actually evaluate the knowledge
in these language models
so this inability to reliably recall
knowledge is a key challenge facing
language models today that'll be the
focus of this talk
recent works have found that language
models can recover some knowledge
including the work that colin presented
last class they've had very encouraging
results
but there's still a way to go as we saw
with the fill in the blank statements
and with these challenges that we just
discussed above
so as a result the past couple years
have had ton of rapid progress in this
area of research in terms of trying to
figure out how do you actually encode
more knowledge in language models
so i also want to motivate why
researchers are interested in building
language models that can more reliably
or call knowledge
and one of these reasons is that the
pre-trained representations are used in
a variety of downstream tasks and some
of these downstream tests are knowledge
intensive
so for instance you might have a
downstream task to extract the relations
between two entities in a sentence
and this is commonly known as relation
extraction and this is much easier if
you have some knowledge of the entities
which could be potentially provided by
this pre-trained language model
representation
and we talk about evaluation we'll talk
about what types of tasks are most
likely to benefit from these knowledge
rich pre-trained representations
and then as a stretch goal some
researchers are starting to propose the
idea
that can language models actually
ultimately be used to replace
traditional knowledge bases so instead
of creating a knowledge base for a fact
like you might right now with sql you
would create a language model with a
natural language prompt
and of course this does require the
language model to have high quality
under calling facts so we might not be
there yet
but it's an interesting direction for us
to be moving towards
so i want to make it super clear what i
mean by a knowledge base
here we're just talking about a
knowledge graph where the nodes in the
graph would be entities
and the edges are going to be relations
between the entities so for example here
we have a subset of a knowledge graph
for franklin d roosevelt and you see the
information about his spouse his place
of birth his date of birth and so on
an important thing to note is it's a
structured way of storing the knowledge
since it's just in a graph form
and you can actually describe these
graphs with knowledge graph triples
which will be an important vocabulary
word throughout this talk so knowledge
graph triple would be um consisting of a
subject entity a relation and then an
object entity so for instance here we
might have franklin d roosevelt date of
birth january 30th 1882 and that would
form a knowledge graph triple
we'll also refer to this as a parent
entity a relation and a tail entity
so wikidata is one very popular
knowledge base you might come across if
you're working this area
it's a free knowledge base that's
actually populated by humans so they're
filling in
these relations and entities and it's
also multilingual
so if you want information from this
knowledge base what you do is write as
you would write a sql query
this is a simplified one but the idea is
you'd want to figure out
the date of birth of franklin roosevelt
so you would write a query like follows
now if instead you want to query a
language model as a knowledge base
you'll have something like this diagram
that you've actually probably seen in
several lectures now
and the idea is you'll train a language
model over this unstructured text
and then you'll use a language model to
just answer these natural language query
statements
so here this is the work on t5 where
they're training t5 over
natural language or just unstructured
text with a span corruption task
and then they're asking t5 when was
franklin d roosevelt born
and the idea is t5 will produce a
textual answer
so you can see this contrast very much
with the old approach of using a
traditional knowledge base where the
knowledge base is structured and you
have the sql statements to query it
so what are the advantages of using
language models over traditional
knowledge bases and why might people
think this this could be a good idea
well for one the language models are
pre-trained over large amounts of
unstructured and unlabeled text
whereas traditional knowledge bases
require manual annotation like with
wikidata people actually populating it
or complex nlp pipelines to extract from
unstructured text into a structured form
that forms a knowledge base
language models can also support more
flexible natural language queries
so if we take the example what does the
final f in the song ufo f stand for
a knowledge base probably won't have a
field for final f so it won't be able to
answer your query
but there's a chance that a language
model could actually learn and have a
response for this natural language query
they also had a less extreme example in
this paper by petroni and others where
maybe your relation would be is works
for in your knowledge base and then you
ask for is working for
and the knowledge base doesn't have an
exact match on the field and so it
returns an empty response
and it's much
it's reasonable to believe that your
language model could figure out that
these relations are similar so if i know
the answer to one of them i probably
know the answer to the other
of course it's not all advantages
there's also many open challenges to
using language models as knowledge bases
so for one it's harder to interpret when
a traditional knowledge base produces an
answer there's actually provenance
information associated with why did it
return that particular query
but with a language model it's really
not clear
why it might produce a prediction the
knowledge is just encoded in the
parameters of the model
it's also harder to trust so you saw
this in assignment 5 where the language
model could produce realistic
predictions but they are incorrect so
it's not easy to know when the language
model actually knows the fact versus
it's using some like biases to make its
prediction
and in the case of the traditional
knowledge base if it doesn't know a fact
it's just going to have an empty
response
and then finally knowledge bases or
language models are harder to modify
so in a knowledge base if you want to
update a fact you just change the fact
directly in the structured data
but in a language model it's not quite
clear how you would do this you could
fine-tune the model longer on the
updated data but how do you know if it
still has some memorization of the old
fact
so there are a lot of open challenges to
this goal of actually using language
models as traditional knowledge bases
but hopefully you see why some people
think this could actually be a good idea
and why researchers are interested in
training language models that can
actually integrate more knowledge
so that brings us to section two of the
talk so i want to pause here just in
case there's any questions
okay
i think that's okay yeah
okay awesome um so now we're going to be
talking about what techniques
researchers are using to actually add
more knowledge to language models
so we're going to talk about three broad
classes of techniques this is by no
means exhaustive but hopefully it gives
you a good overview so that if you want
to dive deeper
you can
so we'll start by talking about adding
pre-trained entity embeddings and for
each section we'll kind of focus on the
first work that you see in the bullets
but we'll also talk about
briefly some of the variants so you see
how the works within each class can
differ and what knobs you can turn
so for adding pre-trained embeddings we
first need to figure out what
pre-trained embeddings would actually be
the most useful to add knowledge to
language models
and this can start with an observation
but facts about the world are usually in
terms of entities
so if we have a fact like washington was
the first president of the united states
we have the entities washington united
states
but pre-trained word embeddings don't
have this notion of entities
so we'd have different word embeddings
for usa united states america and
america even though these all refer to
the same entity
and this makes it challenging for the
language model to actually learn any
representations over these entities
since they may be referred to many ways
in the text
so what if instead we have a single
embedding per entity and we'll refer to
these as entity embeddings
so now you'd have a single entity
embedding for usa united states of
america and america
and whenever you see a phrase in text
referring to this entity
you would use the same entity embedding
and these entity embeddings can actually
be pre-trained to encode this factual
knowledge about the world
and this first class techniques we'll be
looking at would be how do you actually
best use these pre-trained entity
embeddings in a language model
so i need to make a quick note that
these entity embeddings are only useful
to language models though if you can do
another nlp task called entity linking
well
so i'm going to take a quick aside and
explain what is entity linking
so the definition of entity linking is
to link mentions in text to entities in
a knowledge base
i like to think about this in terms of
how you use word embeddings
so if you want to use word embeddings
and you have a sentence you're going to
first tokenize that sentence into words
and then for each word you'll look up
their corresponding id and some word
embedding matrix and now you have your
word
embedding well for entity and bettings
the dictionary lookup isn't so easy
you might have sentences like washington
is the first president united states
well washington has two different
candidates are we talking about george
washington or are we talking about
washington state and these are different
entities that have different entity
embeddings
and the queue ids here would just be
their identifiers and wiki data
and then united states just has a single
entity
so task of entity linking is to figure
out correctly these ambiguous mentions
what entity do they actually link to in
a knowledge base
and there's many different ways you can
do this entity linking so one way you
might be able to do this is to figure
out that oh i see the context word of
president so washington probably links
to george washington
just some more definitions we're going
to refer to washington as i mentioned
the united states as i mentioned and
then the things that the mention could
link to so the two options for
washington are going to be candidates
so this is a whole research area of its
own and i encourage you to check out the
resources at the bottom if you're
interested in learning more
but right now the most important thing
to understand is that entity linking is
what is going to tell us which entity
embeddings are actually relevant to the
text and which ones you want to use as
you iterate through a sequence
megan there are a few
a few questions around here one of them
is so that's entity linking but what
about the relations
um
yeah so some of the works we'll talk
about will only use the entity
embeddings um so some of these have been
pre-trained with relation information
but in the end you only have an entity
embedding
so relation extraction is yet another
nlp test you could also do but yeah here
we're just talking about nc linking
but if you have the knowledge graph you
showed earlier it had relations in it
right do you get any connection between
that and the text
um
i mean that's the goal of relation
extraction right
is to figure out like given the entities
what is relation between them which
would then form the full triple of
head entity tail entity and relation
um okay
then i think people want to know more
about house it's going to be used but
maybe you should go on and show some
examples
yeah i will for sure okay um right
so entity embeddings just to summarize
they're like word embeddings um but
they're for entities in a knowledge base
so you'll have some vector associated
george washington and it should be
meaningful in
embedding space such that maybe the
george washington vector is close to the
vectors for other founding fathers
so we're going to briefly talk about
some methods for a training entity in
betting's
there's knowledge graph embedding
methods you might have heard of the
transient betting method so this starts
from the idea of having these knowledge
graph triples
and you want to learn pre-trained entity
and pre-trained relation embeddings and
you want to be the case that the subject
embedding and the relation embedding the
sum of those two
is close to the object embedding in
vector space so it's an algorithm to
learn that constraint
there's also word entity coccurrence
methods so these build off of word to
back one of them is even called
wikipedia to back and the idea is given
an entity you want to figure out what
words are most likely to co-occur around
it
and then the last method or one of the
other methods that is common now is
actually just using the transformer to
learn representations of an entity by
encoding the entity description and so
blink from facebook is a an approach
that does this
so the methods we'll talk about today
are actually agnostic to how you train
your pre-trained entity embedding but i
think it's important to know that
there's actually a wide variety of
methods to train these preaching entity
embeddings and it's actually not clear
which method is best for using them
downstream and language models
so one of the key challenges of using
pre-trained entity embeddings in
language models is figuring out how to
incorporate them when they're from a
different embedding space than the
language model
and so we'll do or the approaches we'll
look at today
we'll learn a fusion layer to combine
this context and entity information so
we have entity embeddings and we have
the contextualized word embeddings from
our language model
so if we take a sequence of text
and we imagine that j indicates the j
element in a sequence then the challenge
here is we want to figure out how do we
combine some word embedding wj with some
aligned entity embedding ek
so here an alignment could be like in
the example where we had washington was
the first president
washington would be your word embedding
and george washington would be the
aligned entity embedding there
so you could imagine in this case let's
say your wj is washington and your ek
is your entity embedding for george
washington and you want to align them
together so what you can do is learn a
weight matrix wt for the text and w e
for the entity to project these
embeddings to the same dimension before
you sum them and finally take an
activation function over them
so the idea is that by having some
fusion layer mechanism like this you can
actually
use these entity embeddings and these
contextual word embeddings that are in
different embedding spaces and fuse them
together to have this single hidden
representation
for the element in the sequence
so the approaches we'll talk about today
all have some mechanism
either very similar to this or some
variation of this to do this combination
of the context and entity information
so the first approach we're going to
talk about is called ernie enhanced
language representation with informative
entities and so this just builds on what
we've already talked about it uses
pre-trained entity embeddings and
it also uses this notion of a fusion
layer
so the first block in ernie is a text
encoder
which is a multi-layer bi-directional
transformer encoder for their
experiments they use bert but it doesn't
have to be burnt
and this is followed by a knowledge
encoder which has stacked blocks
composed of two multi-headed attentions
one is over the entity embeddings and
one is over your token or subword
embeddings
and then the output of these
contextualized entity and token
embeddings from the multi-headed
attentions
are passed to a fusion layer
which looks very similar to what we just
looked at
but now you also have new word and
entity embeddings that you're producing
uh as output of your fusion layer so you
see this w j
um and this e k which are produced as
the next layer of word and entity
embeddings
so the i here indicates that
it's the ith block in the knowledge
encoder so you'll actually have multiple
stacks of these knowledge encoders and
you'll be doing a fusion of the word
entity embedding producing new word and
entity embeddings and then passing this
to the next block of the knowledge
encoder
so this is what the architecture diagram
looks like on the left side we have the
t encoder or the text encoder
followed by the k encoder or the
knowledge encoder
and then on the right side we have a
zoomed in version of your knowledge
encoder
so you see the multi-headed attentions
over the tokens in orange and then over
the entities in yellow and then you have
this alignment between the word and
entities
with the dashed lines
so they have this example as bob dylan
wrote blowing in the wind in 1962
the entities here are bob dylan and
blowing in the wind
and they have a simple alignment rule
where you want to align the entity to
the first word in the entity phrase
so you want to align bob dylan to bob
that's what the dash line's trying to
indicate and you want a line blowing the
wind to blow
so here this already assumes entity
linking has been done and you know your
entities in advance so you can see that
the entities are actually input into the
model
so after you have your word nt alignment
this goes to the information fusion
layer and this light purple gray color
and then finally it produces these new
word entity embed things as output
and then remember that you have multiple
blocks of these so those will be passed
into the next block of your knowledge
encoder
so how do you actually train this it's
pretty similar to bert you have a mass
language model loss and you have a next
sentence prediction loss
and they also introduce a knowledge
pre-training task which they refer to as
the dea task
it's named after a denoising entity
autoencoder from an icml paper
in 2008
and the idea is they're going to
randomly mask these token entity
alignments so the idea that bob goes to
bob dylan they're going to mask that out
with some random percentage
and then they're going to predict the
corresponding entity for a token out of
the entities in this in the sequence
so this looks like as follows
the summation is over m entities in the
sequence so this would be over bob dylan
and blowing in the wind in the previous
example
and given a particular word they want to
figure out um what entity is it most
likely to align to in that sequence so
does bob align to bob dylan or does bob
align to blowing in the wind
and their motivation for doing this is
that if you don't have this task all
you're ever going to be predicting is
the token with the mass language model
loss
and you really 10 code knowledge should
also probably be predicting over
entities
so by adding this task they have some
kind of task that is actually predicting
the entity
and they also suggest that this might
better fuse the knowledge or the entity
and the word representations than just
using the fusion layer
their final loss is then the summation
of the mass language model loss the next
sentence prediction loss and this dea
knowledge pre-training task loss
so they showed an ablation experiment
that it's actually very important to
have this knowledge pre-training task
so this has um bert on the left-most bar
ernie as the second bar from the left
and so that's with all the features of
ernie and then they try removing the
pre-trained entity embeddings and
removing this knowledge pre-training
task
so you see that bert performs the worst
this isn't very surprising and that
ernie performs the best but what's
interesting is that if you remove the
entity embeddings or you remove the
pre-training task they only do a little
better than bert
and so it's really necessary to actually
use this pre-training task to get the
most use of your pre-trained entity and
bettings
so some strengths of this work were that
they introduced some way to combine
entity and context information through
this fusion layer and this knowledge
pre-training task
and then they also show improved
performance on downstream tasks which
we'll come back to when we talk about
evaluation
but of course there's also some
limitations
so it needs text data with the entities
annotated as input and this is even true
for downstream tasks so if you remember
on the architecture diagram we had the
entity entity information actually input
into the architecture but it's not very
realistic that you're necessarily going
to have a good entity linker for any
downstream tasks that you want to use
ernie on
and the next challenge is this requires
more pre-training of your language model
so now you don't just need to pretend
burt but you also need to pre-train your
knowledge encoder on top
for the first challenge we're going to
actually talk about a work that presents
a solution to address this for the
second challenge i encourage you to
check out the footnote on the bottom
this introduces a work that
actually uses pre-trained entity
embeddings uses them in a language model
and doesn't require any more
pre-training so it's pretty cool
uh i guess that's all i have for ernie
so i want to pause here for questions
well here's one that's up here so on the
fusion layer it has it observed that
passing the entity embedding into a
fusion layer to combine with word
embedding is more powerful than just
concatenating the entity embedding onto
the end of the word embedding question
mark yeah so i guess people are still a
little bit confused as to
the motivation for that fusion layer and
so i guess here is this the simplest
strategy would be since you've got the
entity linking you could just
concatenate entity embeddings onto the
end of word embeddings and do regular
would that work just as well
um
i think the idea is it wouldn't because
if you imagine that let's say your
magnitudes are very different um
you need some way to i guess align the
spaces so that anything meaningful in
the entity embedding space is still
meaningful in the word embedding space
so if you're close in the word embedding
space you also would be you'd want to be
close in entity embedding space so i
guess that's one argument
yeah
i mean i mean i think the question isn't
you know it's a good question as people
say i mean it's not completely obvious
that it wouldn't work to do that it
seems like one of the potential problems
is
some words have entity
links to them and some words don't and
so you then you'd sort of have zero
vectors for the ones that don't have
anything that's a good point linked and
that might
act a bit weirdly but
yeah in this case when they don't have
entities linked which is a great point
um yeah the first equation just
simplifies to the first term plus the
bias so like there's an obvious solution
in that case when you're not
concatenating that you just don't add on
the term um
yeah that could be one reason too
okay are there any other questions
[Music]
i think you can go on
okay cool
um
right so now we're talking about novert
and this is from the same folks that
introduced the elmo work
and the idea here is that they're going
to
pre-train an integrated entity linker as
an extension to bird
and so
their loss function will now be the
summation of the next sentence
prediction the mass language model loss
and this entity linking loss so instead
of the knowledge pre-training dea task
from ernie we'll have an entity linking
loss
and the idea of the entity linker is
you'll now have just as normal sequence
as input and the integrated empty linker
will figure out what are the entities in
the sentence and um or what are the
mentions in the sentence what are the
candidates of those mentions and then
what should be the scores those entities
or the candidates given the context of
the sentence and so this is all done now
as part of the model rather than
requiring it as some external pipeline
stage before you could even use ernie
for instance
so now for downstream tasks you no
longer need these entity annotations
your integrated anti-linker will figure
out what the correct entity is and be
able to use the correct entity embedding
so there's also this idea that learning
is entity linking may actually better
encode knowledge than this dea
pre-training task because they show that
nobody actually outperforms ernie on
downstream tasks
so one reason this may occur is that if
you think about the the dea task it's
actually a bit simpler than just entity
linking so you're trying to predict for
instance um
what bob linked to out of bob dylan and
blowing in the wind and it's much easier
even as a human to see that bob dylan
will more likely link to or bob will
more likely link to bob dylan
than that bob will link to blowing in
the wind
and anti-linking task you actually have
a much harder set of candidates to
predict over you're not just looking at
the ones in a sentence so does
washington link to george washington or
washington state actually requires you
using more information about the entity
so given it's a harder task it's not too
surprising that it might perform better
than just this easier
knowledge pre-training task that ernie
introduced
so otherwise nobert has a lot of
similarities to ernie it uses a fusion
layer that combines this context and
entity information
and it introduces some knowledge
pre-training task
so i'd say a high-level takeaway is if
you want to use pre-trained entity
embeddings in a language model you'll
probably at least want to consider both
of these components in terms of actually
going to integrate the preaching entity
embeddings and
take the most advantage of the knowledge
in them as possible
so that brings us to the next class of
techniques which is using external
memory
and here we'll mainly focus on this work
called kglm and then we'll also briefly
talk about k n lm
so the previous methods that we've
talked about have relied on pre-change
entity embeddings to encode the factual
knowledge from knowledge bases
and the one problem with this or one of
the problems with this is if you want to
let's say modify your knowledge base you
now need to retrain your entity
embeddings and then retrain your
language model on top of those entity
embeddings
so this begs the question are there more
direct ways in pre-trained entity
embeddings to provide the model factual
knowledge
and so we're going to talk about is how
you can actually use an external memory
or a key value store to give the model
access to either knowledge graph triples
or context information
and a key thing about this external
memory is that it's independent of the
learned model parameters
so this means you can actually support
injecting and updating factual knowledge
you can do this directly to the symbolic
external memory by let's say changing
the value for a particular key or maybe
adding another key
and you don't have to
pre-train or retrain your entity
embeddings when you make this change
and the approaches we'll talk about
today can actually even have these
updates to the external memory without
more pre-training of the language model
so that's pretty neat
and then another benefit of using
external memory over these pre-trained
nc embedding approaches is they can also
be more interpretable so if you have an
a bug or not a bug an air in your model
where it's not predicting a correct fact
it's very challenging to figure out with
pre-trained anti-embeddings um what the
problem might be was it the original
knowledge base was it the encoding in
the entity embeddings is it how the
language model is using the entity
embeddings and here you have a little
more information with an external memory
and that you can look in the external
memory and see was the fact in the
external memory
was was it not in external memory and so
on so it adds a little bit more
interpretability than just using these
pre-trained ncm bettings as an indirect
way to encode the knowledge base
so the first work we're going to talk
about is called kglm and unlike the
other approaches we've talked about so
far this actually uses lstms and not
transformers
so the key idea here is to condition the
language model on a knowledge graph
so recall with a standard language model
we want to predict the next word given
the previous words in the sequence
well now we also want to predict the
next entity given the previous words in
the sequence and given the previous
entities in the sentence
or the entities that are relevant to the
sentence i should say
so kglm will be building a local
knowledge graph as it iterates over the
sequence
and a local knowledge graph is just a
subset of a full knowledge graph that
only has the entities that are actually
relevant to the sequence
oops so if we have this example here um
a simplified example from the paper
that super mario land is a game
developed by blank and super mario land
here is an entity
you'd want a local knowledge graph as
follows where you see that super mario
land is in the local knowledge graph but
we also have the relations to super
mario land to other entities that are
copied from the full knowledge graph
into this local knowledge graph
and you would build up this local
knowledge graph as you iterate over the
sentence so whenever you see an entity
you would add it to the local knowledge
graph as well as its relations to other
entities
so obviously this is a much smaller
example than what would really have all
the relations to super mario land just
for the purpose of the example
but hopefully it's clear that all of
these are relevant to the sequence
something important to note here is that
this does assume that the entities are
known during training
so that you do have this entity
annotated data for training and
therefore your local knowledge graph is
always the ground truth local knowledge
graph as you iterate over the sequence
so why might this be a good idea to do
this
well here the next word you want to
predict is nintendo
and you may notice that nintendo is in
your local knowledge graph
so sometimes this local knowledge graph
can actually serve as a very strong
signal for what you want to predict for
your next word
now you may be thinking well this
wouldn't always be helpful and that's
true is all as well
so if you look at just like the third
word in the sequence and you want to
predict that word um so is a game
for instance
well if this isn't in the local
knowledge graph this wouldn't be
necessarily that helpful
you would just do a standard language
model prediction
or if you're at the beginning of the
sequence your local knowledge graph is
empty so of course you're not going to
get any signal from it
so the first question they ask in kglm
is how can a language model know when to
use a local knowledge graph and when it
might actually be useful for predicting
the next word
so we're going to keep the same example
as a running example and we have our
local knowledge graph here
we now have an lstm that looks similar
to the representations you've seen
throughout this class
and normally you've seen the lstm
predicts the next word
well now we're also going to use the
lstm to predict the next type of the
word
so is the next word going to be a
related entity meaning it's in the local
knowledge graph already
is it going to be a new entity meaning
it's not in a local knowledge graph or
is it going to be not an entity in which
case you just revert to a normal lstm
prediction
and they're going to use the lstm hidden
state to do this prediction of the type
of the next word
over this three-way three different
classes that they might want to consider
so in the case of super mario land as a
game developed by nintendo we saw that
this would be a related entity case
because you saw that nintendo was in the
local knowledge graph
for the other cases super mario land
would be a new entity case since it's
the local knowledge graph is empty at
that point
and then any of the words between super
mario land and nintendo would be
non-entity as they're just a standard
lstm language model prediction that
doesn't involve any entities
so now we need to talk about what the
language model actually does in these
three different scenarios to predict the
next entity and the next word
so we're going to keep the example up at
the top in case you want to refer back
to three different cases
and we're going to start with the
related entity case
so here we assume that the next word or
entity is actually in your local
knowledge graph and remember that we can
describe a knowledge graph in terms of
triples so in terms of uh pairs of
parent entities relations and tail
entities
and in the case of predicting the next
word as nintendo
there's only one possible parent entity
in the local knowledge graph which is
super mario land
and the goal is you want to figure out
what is the most relevant triple that
will be useful in helping to predict the
next word
so in this case you could have the
triple super mario land publisher
nintendo you might have the triple super
mario land genre platform game which of
these is actually helpful in predicting
that nintendo should be the next word
so here what you would want kglm to do
is predict that the top scoring parent
entity is super mario land and the top
scoring relation is publisher and you
can see there are actually contextual
cues in a sentence that could help you
figure out uh which triple you're
talking about
and then given that your top scoring
parent entity is super mario land and
your top scoring relation is publisher
you can figure out that using knowledge
graph triples the tail entity has to be
nintendo
and therefore this gives you a strong
signal that the next word will be
nintendo
so the goal is you're going to find the
top scoring parent entity and the top
scoring relation using the nodes in your
local knowledge graph and you can do
this by using the lstm hidden state
combined with pre-trained entity and
relation embeddings
so i do admit i cheated here a little
bit and that this does use pre-trained
embeddings but hopefully you'll see by
the end of this discussion why i think
it fits a bit better in this external
memory use case as well
so what they're going to do is they're
going to take a softmax using the lstm
hidden state and the entity embeddings
for each of the potential parent
entities and then we'll take this top
scoring one as a parent entity
and they'll do the same thing for the
relation embeddings
the next entity is then just this tail
entity from the knowledge graph triple
so it's relatively trivial to figure out
what the next
entity should be once you've figured out
the top scoring parent entity and your
top scoring relation
and then finally to predict the next
word they take the vocabulary and they
expand it to include different aliases
that could refer to that entity
so what we mean by aliases here are
phrases that could refer to the entity
and text
so you might not just call it nintendo
you might also say nintendo company or
copai and you want any of these to be
possible words that you could predict as
a next word
so the goal of this vocabulary expansion
is to increase the probability that the
next word you predict will actually be
related to this next entity
so new entity case is a bit simpler this
means that the entity that you're
predicting is not in the local knowledge
graph so you're not getting any signal
from this local knowledge graph that
you've been building up
and all you want to do is find the top
scoring entity in the full knowledge
graph and you can do this using the lstm
hidden state and pretend ntm bettings
similar to how we found the score for
the top parent entity
your next entity will just be the top
scoring entity out of the full knowledge
graph and then your next word is once
again this vocabulary expanded to
include aliases of that entity
the not in empty case is the simplest
you just revert to normal lstm you don't
have an x entity to predict and your
next word is just the most likely next
token over your normal vocabulary
so here's a diagram from their paper
that hopefully summarizes and makes even
clearer
what i just went over
so they have a longer example than the
one we are looking at but it's the same
prediction as nintendo is the next word
and they have their predictions in red
so this is what they want kglm to
predict
the three different cases are in the
horizontals and we see that here you're
in the related entity case since
nintendo is in your local knowledge
graph
so they want kglm to predict that
nintendo should be a related entity type
of word
that super mario land should be its
parent entity that publisher should be
the relevant relation and as a result
the next entity is nintendo and then
they expand their vocabulary you see the
aliases
aliases of nintendo at the bottom and
then finally they actually predict
nintendo as the next word
and the other cases just summarize what
we also already went over
so i find that kglm actually outperforms
gpt2 and awd lstm which is a strong lstm
language model on a fat completion task
similar to the fill in the blank
examples that we looked at at the
beginning of the talk
they also find qualitatively that
compared to gpt 2 kglm tends to predict
more specific tokens since it can
predict these tokens from
just copying from the local knowledge
graph
whereas gpt2 will tend to predict more
generic tokens so if you want to predict
the birthplace of someone gpt2 is more
likely to predict new york for example
and kglm might predict some obscure
place
and then they had these really cool set
of experiments where they showed that
kglm actually supports modifying or
updating facts
so they made a direct change in the
knowledge graph and then they saw what
is the change in kglm's predictions
so they have this example where um the
sequence was barack obama was born on
blank
they had their knowledge graph triple as
barack obama's original birth date and
then their most likely next tokens were
as expected august 4th 1961
and then they just changed their
knowledge graph so they changed the
birth date of obama they said okay he's
now born 2013.
and they look to see what the next uh
predictions were for kglm
and it changed its predictions to match
what was in the local knowledge graph
so this is something that's pretty cool
and that really only external memory
approaches um can do compared to these
to the original pre-trained
anti-embedding approaches we talked
about
and i think it's one of the one of the
reasons that kglm at least in my opinion
fits better in these external memory use
cases
right so the next slide is a different
paper so i guess i'll take questions on
kglm
if there are any
it's a pretty complex method so feel
free to have questions
yeah um could you one more time explain
what the definition of the local
knowledge graph is in relationship to
the global knowledge graph
yep um
so local knowledge graph is supposed to
be a subset of the full knowledge graph
and it's only supposed to consist of
entities that are actually have actually
been seen in the sequence
um
as well as
uh
their relevant entities
okay oops
all right so here you see that super
mario land is in the local knowledge
graph because super mario land is an
entity that is seen in the sequence and
then you also want to copy over all the
edges from super mario land that would
be in the full knowledge graph
so this is just a subset of them for the
purpose of the example but you see that
super mario land has an edge nintendo to
game boy to platform game and so you
would copy all edges that super mario
land has to another node in the full
knowledge graph
and they know in advance like they have
the labels here for what the entities
are during training so that's how they
can actually create this ground truth
knowledge graph
and then briefly a student asked why we
can't just use the whole knowledge graph
and i gave an answer but maybe you know
better
um yeah i think the idea is the signal
will be much stronger if you just use a
local knowledge graph so in the softmax
for the related entity case you would
just be
predicting over the potential parent
entities in your local knowledge graph
which is a much smaller set than what's
in your full knowledge graph
so i guess it's more likely that you're
going to predict something that is
correct in that case then when you have
like five million or so entities in your
full knowledge graph it's also much
cheaper to compute
um in this case there's only a single
parent entity but you could have
multiple parent entities that you're
trying to compute which one's most
likely over
is that what you were also thinking john
um yeah i mainly just said uh
uh efficiency so the the signal thing is
cool too
um
here's an exciting question what about
queries that require more than one
uh step in the knowledge graph such as
the location of the publisher of super
mario land
um
yeah that's a good question
so the idea is like can it support those
types like does it support multi-hop
kind of building of the knowledge graph
yeah yeah how does kglm perform in those
cases
yeah i don't know that's a very good
question they build up the knowledge
graph so that it's just single hop as
far as i know but like if you saw the
other entities
if you were to see the entities along
the hops it would have them in the local
knowledge graph um
yeah that's a good question i don't know
if they explored that
great
okay
um let's move along then
so the next piece of work we're going to
talk about you guys have actually
briefly seen in the natural language
generation lecture
but i'm going to go over it again
quickly here um so unlike the other
works that we talked about that used
knowledge graph triples this is actually
going to take kind of a looser notion of
knowledge in that the knowledge will
just be encoded in the text in the
training data set
so this is called k n lm and the idea is
that we're building the idea that
language models not only learn to
predict the next word and text but they
also learn these representations of text
and the authors suggest that it might
actually be easier to learn similarities
between text sequences than it is to
predict the next word in the text
so you have this example that dickens is
the author of blank and dickens wrote
blank and they argue that it's easier to
tell for a human but also for a model
that these sequences are similar and
they should probably have the same next
word even if you don't know what the
next word is
um so that's suggesting that you know
it's easier to learn these similarities
than it is to actually predict the next
word
and they argue that this is even more
true for long tail patterns where it's
very challenging for the model to
predict that the next word is some
rarely seen token or rare entity
than it is to find another similar
sequence that it's already seen and just
copy the next word from that sequence
so what they propose to do is store all
representations of text sequences in a
nearest neighbor data store
and then at inference
what you'll want to do is you find the k
most similar sequence as a text
you then retrieve their corresponding
values so you just peek at those
sequences and see what were their next
words
and then you combine the probability
from this
nearest neighbor data store with just a
typical language model prediction and so
they call this an interpolation step in
that they're waiting how much to pay
attention to the probability from this k
n approach and how much to pay attention
to this language model approach
and the lambda here is just a
hyperparameter they tune
so they have this diagram from their
paper where they want to predict the
next word in the sequence shakespeare's
play blank
so what they do is they have all the
training contacts already encoded in
their data store so they have
representations of all the training
contacts
and then they compute a representation
of their text context and they want to
figure out
which representations in the training
context are most similar to this text
test context representation
and so here in the external memory view
of things the keys would be the
representations of the training context
and the values would be the next words
so to get the k nearest training
representations um they then copy over
their values so that's what you see with
this macbeth hamlet macbeth example they
have a normalization step where they
convert this to probability space
um and then finally they have an
aggregation step so if a
word is seen as the next word and
several of these uh k nearest neighbors
then they want to count more for that so
that's why they aggregate say c macbeth
twice it means macbeth is more likely
um
and then finally they have this
interpolation step where they try to
balance between the classification
probabilities from the language model
and from the k n
approach
so some immediate observation you might
have is this seems really expensive
they do propose ways to
kind of try to minimize the expense of
actually having to store all the
training contacts in this data store
because they actually store it for every
single window of next word in the
training context
and you can do quantization on some
nearest neighbor approaches to try to
make this less expensive
but i imagine this would still be pretty
expensive for really large training data
sets
they also have some cool experiments
that show that this is very good for
domain adaptation so if you take your
language model and you have a new domain
that you want to apply your language
model to you could just create a nearest
neighbor data store of your new domain
so you
encode all the representations of that
new domain you stick it in a data store
and then you can just use your language
model
with these k n probabilities as well
just immediately on this new domain
without actually having to further train
your language model
so i thought that was a pretty cool
use case of this external memory
approach
so while it doesn't leverage knowledge
bases directly it does have this loose
knowledge of or loose idea of encoding
knowledge that is in a textual
representation form into some external
memory that the model can then take
advantage of
um
that's all i have for this approach are
there any questions on this
approach well
so only one person is asking how does
the k n make predictions for the next
word
the k neighbors are for the context
instead of the next word
oh okay that wasn't clear um so the keys
are the representations of the context
the values in your external memory are
the next words so when you figure out
you figure out your nearest neighbors
using your keys and then you copy over
their values so it does actually know
what the next words are for each of
those representations
okay
um so finally we're going to talk about
how you can just modify the training
data to better encode knowledge and
language models
so approaches we've talked about so far
are actually incorporating knowledge
explicitly by using either pre-trained
embeddings or an external memory
we also want to talk about how can you
just incorporate knowledge implicitly
through the unstructured text
so what we're going to do is either mask
or corrupt the data to introduce
additional training tasks that require
factual knowledge to
figure out what data was masked for
instance
so this has some clear advantages it
doesn't have any additional memory or
computation requirements you don't have
a data store to deal with you don't have
extra knowledge encoder layers to train
all you do is modify the training data
and you don't have to modify your
architecture either so you can continue
using your favorite bert model and just
make these changes to the training data
so the first work we're going to look at
is called wklm weekly supervised
knowledge pre-training language model or
pre-trained language model
and the key idea here is to train the
model to distinguish between true and
false knowledge
so they're going to corrupt the data by
replacing mentions in the text with
mentions that refer to different
entities of the same type to create what
they refer to as negative knowledge
statements
and then the model will just predict has
the entity been replaced or corrupted
this type constraint is necessary to
make sure that
or to encourage the model to actually
use factual knowledge to figure out if
this corruption is taking place so you
could imagine if you replace it with
something that's not realistic at all
the model could just
be basing its prediction based on is
this sentence linguistically correct
so as an example we have a true
knowledge statement as
jk rowling is the author of harry potter
and then we want to modify this to
replace it with another author so let's
say we change this to j r tolkien as the
author of harry potter
so you can see that this requires some
amount of knowledge
background knowledge to actually be able
to figure out which statement's true and
which statement is false the idea is
that the model will be able to predict
for each of these mentions
whether it's a true or false mention
so this diagram here is from the paper
and hopefully explains this a bit better
they have the original article on the
left and then they have the replaced
article with the corruptions on the
right and the entities are are in blue
so what they do is for a given entity
they first look up its type they find
other entities of that type
and then they randomly sample the entity
and get an alias of it to replace in the
text so they're going to play stan lee
for instance with brian johnson and
marvel comics with dc comics and their
placements are in red on the right
and then the idea is that the model be
able to predict for each of these
mentions um was it replaced or not so in
the case of brian johnson they have the
red x for this is a false mention and
in the case of the true mentions they
have the check mark
so it's a pretty simple approach but
they actually show that it can help the
model
increase the amount of knowledge that's
encoded in parameters
okay so wklm uses an entity replacement
loss to train the model to distinguish
between these true and false mentions
and this just looks like a binary
classification loss where your true
mentions are on the left and your false
mentions are on the right and you want
to increase the probability that this p
of e given c so the probability entity
given the context you want to increase
that for the true mentions and decrease
it for the false mentions
the total loss is then just a
combination of the mass language model
loss and this entity replacement loss
the mass language mods the mass language
model loss is defined at the token level
and the entity replacement loss is
defined at the entity level
meaning it's not just over sub words
it's even potentially over words if you
have
multi-word entities phrases for instance
and this is an important point
or an important theme that we really see
occurring throughout these works that
we'll look at in that
modifying the data at the entity level
seems to be an important component of
actually increasing the amount of
knowledge that a language model can
encode
so they find that wklm improves over
bert and gpt2 in fact completion tasks
like the fill in the blank statements
that we looked at at the beginning
they also find that it improves over the
ernie paper that we talked about on a
downstream task
and they had a set of ablation
experiments where they looked at can you
just remove this mass language model
loss now
and if you just train bert for longer do
you really need this entity replacement
loss
so that's what the table here is looking
at um the second row is looking at if we
remove the mass language model lost what
happens
we see that it performs much worse
without the mass language model loss so
you really need both losses their
intuition there was the mass language
model loss
helps to encode just general language
understanding
and then training bert for longer um
performs much worse than using his
entity replacement loss so this
motivates even farther that you really
do need um or the entity replacement
loss is actually really helping encode
more knowledge in these language models
so in addition to corrupting the data
we're also going to look at can we just
mask the data differently can we be more
clever about how we do the masking
and this is a thread in several recent
works
so there's actually another paper called
ernie so this is different than the one
we talked about before and this is
enhanced representation through
knowledge integration
and what they do is show improvements on
downstream chinese nlp tasks by doing
phrase level and entity level masking so
instead of just masking out sub words
they're going to mask out phrases of
multiple words and entities
the full phrase of an entity which
corresponds to
some entity and text that they might
find with like nar techniques for
example
and then the second work is actually
something you heard about in the last
lecture which is the idea of using
salient span masking to mask out salient
spans and a saline span is just a named
entity or a date so you can see this is
pretty similar to what ernie is doing
and they found that using salient span
masking actually significantly helped t5
performance on these closed domain
question answering tasks
so just to make sure we're all on the
same page um with the different masking
techniques this diagram from the ernie
paper is comparing to what bert does
versus what ernie does the top shows
that ernie masked out the subword tokens
or that bert massed out the subway
tokens whereas ernie massed out phrases
like a series of as well as entities
like jk rowling
there's some interesting results on
showing that salient span masking is
helping encode more knowledge in these
representations
so on the left we're looking at the
results of the original paper that
proposed salient sand salient span
masking so this is the realm work and
the idea here was that they were
training a knowledge retriever so it's
actually more of an external memory
class of techniques but they find that
by using the salient span masking
technique
they could actually train a much better
knowledge retriever so it's a good
example of
how these techniques are really
complementary so while i presented three
classes of techniques you can definitely
get benefits by doing multiple
techniques together
and they found that doing silence fan
masking compared to using masking from
bert which would be the random uniform
masks or doing
random masking of spans from a paper
called spanbert um it performs much
better to do salience band masking so
you see like a 38
exact match score versus like a 32 exact
match score for instance
and on the right we have results um
from fine tuning t5 with either ceiling
span masking or the span corruption task
that you saw in assignment five and you
can see that on these different qa data
sets science band masking does
significantly better than just using the
span corruption
technique
so this really suggests that
doing the salient span masking and
masking out these salient spans of these
entities is in fact helping to encode
more knowledge in these language models
so to recap we talked about three
different classes of techniques to add
knowledge to language models
we talked about using pre-trained entity
embeddings these weren't too difficult
to apply to existing architectures and
as a way to leverage this knowledge
graph pre-training
but it's a rather indirect way of
incorporating knowledge and it could be
hard to interpret
we also talked about approaches to add
an external memory
this could support modifying the
knowledge base it was also easier to
interpret
but they tended to be more complex in
implementation like we saw at kglm and
they also required more memory like we
saw with the k nlm approach
and then finally we talk about modifying
the training data
so this requires no model changes or
additional computation it also might be
the easiest to theoretically analyze so
it's actually an active area research
right now
but still an open question if modifying
the training data is always as effective
as model changes and what the trade-offs
are in terms of amount of data required
versus doing one of these other
knowledge enhancement approaches
so that leads us to section three um so
i guess i'll pause again for questions
i think we may be good
awesome okay um so section three is
about how researchers are actually going
about evaluating the knowledge and
language models and um i guess how some
of the techniques we actually just
talked about stand up in this evaluation
so first we're going to talk about
probes which
don't require any fine tuning of the
language model and then we're going to
talk about downstream tasks which look
at how well do these pre-trained
representations actually transfer their
knowledge to other tasks
so one of the initial works in this area
was called llama and this really started
a series of works to look into how much
knowledge is already encoded in these
language models
so their question was how much
relational common sense and factual
knowledge is in off-the-shelf language
models such as taking pre-trained
language models and evaluating the
knowledge in them
and this is without any additional
training or fine-tuning
so they mainly constructed a set of what
they refer to as closed statements and
these are just the fill in the blank
statements that we actually drew from at
the beginning of the talk we have some
more examples here
and they manually created these
templates of closed statements using
knowledge graph triples and question
answering pairs from existing data sets
they wanted to compare pre-trained
language models to supervise relation
extraction and question answering
systems to see how do these language
models that were trained in an
unsupervised fashion compared to these
baseline systems that are not only
supervised but really targeted for this
task of knowledge extraction
and their goal was to evaluate the
knowledge in existing pre-trained
language models and a key point about
this is like they're just using the
language models as they are available to
researchers so this means there could be
differences in the pre-training corpora
for example
so when you look at the following table
and you're comparing language models
also keep in mind that
these don't like account for the
differences in the pre-trained corpora
so a lot of these language models
probably look familiar to you either
from
previous lectures or maybe your final
projects
and what we see is that overall
bert base and bert large pre-trained
models are performing much better than
the previous language or the other
language models here
i guess i forgot to mention what mean
precision at one is um this is a pretty
simple metric the idea is if you look at
the blank and you look at the top
predictions for the top prediction for
the blank is it correct or not so that's
what precision at 1 means precision at
10 would be let's look at the top 10
predictions is the correct prediction in
the top 10.
um
so in addition to bert large and base
performing well overall we do see that
in the t-rex data set the relation
extraction baseline is performing a bit
better than bert
one thing they notice here that's pretty
interesting is that this data set has a
lot of different types of relations and
relations can be classified in terms of
are they a one-to-one relation are they
an end-to-one relation are they an
end-to-end relation
an example of a one-to-one relation
would be your student id relation so you
have a unique student id an example of
an end-to-end relation would be they
enrolled in relation so there's lots of
students enrolled in lots of classes so
this would be an end-to-end relation
and they find that bert really struggles
on these end-to-end relations
so while it performs better than
relation extraction baseline on some
types of relations overall it does
pretty terribly on these end-to-end
relations so overall it does a bit worse
than the baseline on this trx data set
they also compare to squad on docker qa
and they find that it does a fair amount
worse they note that the language model
is not fine-tuned here and also has no
access to an information retrieval
system
and then they look at the precision at
10 they find that this gap between
docker qa's performance and bert
actually closes quite a bit which
suggests that these language models do
have some amount of knowledge encoded in
them and that they're even
competitive with these knowledge
extraction supervised baselines
so you can also try out examples on
their github repo for the llama probe
we have an example
that was from their repo that was the
cat is on the mask
you can see what the top 10 predictions
are
to fill in the closed statement here
they have the cat is on the phone
so this can be a fun way just to figure
out what factual common sense knowledge
is in existing language models and it's
pretty easy
to use with this interactive prompt
so some limitations of the llama probe
are that it can be hard to understand
why the models perform well when they do
so for instance bert might just be
predicting the most popular token and
this happens to be right maybe it's just
memorizing co-occurrence patterns and
doesn't really understand
the knowledge statement and doesn't
understand
what the fact is
it might also just be identifying
similarities between surface forms of
the subject and object so for instance
example pope clement vii has a position
of blank
even if you don't know anything about
pope clement vii you might be able to
figure out that pope is a likely next
word
for this uh triple or for this template
so the problem with this is if the model
is just making these predictions based
on these surface forms or co-occurrence
patterns
it's difficult to know for actually
evaluating the knowledge in the model
maybe it's just making correct
predictions for other reasons
and the more subtle issue that we've
brought up is that language models might
be just sensitive to the phrasing of the
statement
so for each uh
triple in their data set or for each
relation their data set they just had
one manually defined template and
qualitatively they found that if they
just make small changes as a template it
could actually change whether or not the
model could recall the correct
prediction or not
and so this means that the probe results
are really a lower bound on the
knowledge that's encoded in the language
model
so if you change the phrasing it's
possible that the model might show that
actually does have the knowledge encoded
in it
so the next lines of work we'll talk
about um are really building on these
two limitations of this original llama
probe
so the first one is called lama oon or
llama unhelpful names and the key idea
is to remove these examples from lama
that can be answered without the
relational knowledge so this is kind of
addressing the first limitation on the
last slide
so they observed that bert relies under
surface forms entities might not be
using knowledge to make these
predictions this includes the string
match situation that we talked about
with the pope
this also
is dealing with the revealing person
name issue that you saw in assignment
five
so this is where the name could be an
incorrect prior for the native language
of someone their place of birth their
nationality
they have this example from the table or
from the paper where they look at
different
people names or person's names and then
they look at births prediction for their
native language and these are all french
speaking actors and burt just predicts
very biased and stereotypical
languages for these particular names
so this can really work both ways it can
lead bert to make incorrect predictions
and sometimes or in some cases but it
could also work to make or to let bert
make correct predictions even if it has
no factual knowledge of those people so
that's the issue they're trying to get
at here is do we know that bert actually
knows this fact or is it just using
some bias to make its prediction
so what they do is they introduce a
couple heuristics to basically just
filter out these examples from the llama
probe um that can either be solved by
the string match setting or the
surveilling person name setting
so they make a harder subset of the
llama data set essentially
they find that when they test bert on
this harder subset that its performance
drops about eight percent
but when they test their knowledge
enhanced model which they call ebert the
score only drops about one percent
so it's possible that as we make harder
knowledge probes we'll actually see even
bigger differences in the performance of
knowledge enhanced models to models
without these knowledge enhancements
the next piece of work we'll talk about
is actually getting at this issue of um
the phrasing of the
the prompt might actually trigger
different responses from the language
model so the language model might know
the fact but it might fail
on the task due to the phrasing
one reason this might happen is the
pre-training is on different contexts
and sentence structures in the query
so for example you might have in your
pre-training corpus the birthplace of
barack obama is honolulu hawaii and this
might be something you see in wikipedia
for instance that's a common training
data set
and then as a researcher you write
barack obama is born in blank and you
can see that these sentence structures
are pretty different so the model might
have seen the first fact but the
sentence structure difference is
actually enough to confuse it so it
can't answer this query
so what they do is they generate a lot
more of these prompts by mining
templates from wikipedia one of their
techniques actually uses dependency
parsing and also generating paraphrase
prompts by taking
inspiration from the machine translation
literature and using back translation
so generate a lot more prompts to try to
query the language models and figure out
do small variations in the prompt
trigger the correct prediction from the
language model
they also experiment then sombling
prompts so if we give the model multiple
prompts and then take
some probability averaged over these
different prompts
can we improve the performance on the
model returning the correct prediction
so we give it a higher chance of seeing
a context that it might have actually
seen during pre-training
they find that the performance on llama
increases when they either use a top
performing prompt or when they use this
ensembling approach
so this suggests that the original llama
really was a lower bound on the amount
of knowledge encoded in these language
models and
changing the phrasing can actually help
the
model recall the correct answer
this table table's a bit frightening but
they find that small changes in the
query can lead to really large gains on
performance so if you just have a query
like x plays in y position
and then you change that to x plays that
y position this can actually lead to
like a 23 accuracy gain on this
particular relation
in terms of the model actually being
able to recall the correct answer
or even just x was created in a y to x
is created in y 10 accuracy gain
so i think this motivates the need to
not only develop better ways to query
these models but probably also build
language models that are actually more
robust to the query itself
so in addition to probes another way to
evaluate these language models is by
looking at how well they transfer
from the pre-trained representation to
downstream tasks
and so the idea here is you're actually
going to fine-tune the pre-trained
representation on different downstream
tasks similar to how you would evaluate
bert on glue tasks
some common tasks that are used for this
are relation extraction entity typing
and question answering relation
extraction is where you want to predict
the relation between two entities so
this is getting back at one of the
questions earlier in the talk in terms
of well how do you get the relation
that's the edges in these knowledge
bases
so given two entities you learn a model
to predict what is a relation between
them
entity typing is a task of given an
entity what is the type of the entity so
here alice rob the bank you want to
predict her as a criminal
and then you guys are very familiar with
question answering
so the idea of these comment of these
tasks is that they're knowledge
intensive so they're good candidates to
see how well do these pre-trained
representations actually transfer their
knowledge to these downstream tasks
here we're looking at the performance on
a relation extraction benchmark called
tacrid and all the models that we show
here were at one point state of the art
on tacrid
so this cgcn is a graph convolutional
neural network over dependency trees the
burt lstm base is a it's one of the
first works that showed that you could
actually get state of the art
performance with bert on relation
extraction and this is just putting lstm
layer over bert's output
ernie is the work that we talked about
with the pre-trained entity embeddings
matching the blanks we didn't get to
today but it's a really interesting work
about learning meaningful relation
representations and it falls more into
the
training data modification approaches
and that they are actually masking out
entities again
and then no birt is what we talked about
um the w and w here means they actually
encode two knowledge bases in novert so
they're encoding wordnet and they're
also encoding wikipedia
and the high level takeaway from this
table is that you can see that the
recent knowledge enhanced models have
achieved state of the art over
the original models that once performed
very well on tack grid and you we have
about five f1 gains here
another interesting takeaway from this
table is there seems to be a trade-off
in the size of the language model that's
necessary to get a certain performance
so if you just um consider the size of
the language model then no birth
performs the best
but if you
don't consider that then it's highs with
matching the blanks
so overall this is pretty good evidence
that these knowledge enhanced methods
are in fact transferring to these
knowledge intensive downstream tasks
that can really take advantage of these
pre-trained representations
we also have results on entity typing so
here we're comparing a slightly
different set of models some of the
baselines are lstm models that were
designed for entity typing and we have
ernie and nobert um leading the the
i guess leaderboard here on the entity
typing task of open entity and we see
gains of about 15 f1 points with ernie
and no bert so once again we really do
see that um these knowledge rich
pre-trained representations are
transferring and helping on these
knowledge intensive downstream tasks
so just to recap we talked about probes
which evaluate the knowledge already
present in models these don't require
any more training
but it can be challenging to construct
benchmarks to actually
make sure you're testing the knowledge
in these language models it can also be
challenging to construct the queries
used in the probe
we then talked about downstream tasks
these are a bit of an indirect way to
evaluate knowledge and that they have
this extra component of fine tuning but
it's a good way to evaluate how useful
is this knowledge-rich pre-trained
representation in actual applications
so i just uh touched on the exciting
work in this area but there's many other
directions if you want to dive more into
this so there's retrieval augmented
language models which learn knowledge
retrievers
to figure out what documents might be
relevant for predicting the next word
there's work in modifying the knowledge
in language models so i talked about how
this is one of the obstacles and
challenges to using language models as
knowledge bases so there's been recent
work in this area
we also saw how important the knowledge
pre-training task was well there's many
papers that are proposing different
tasks to do the knowledge pre-training
so it's still an open question in terms
of what tasks are best to add to encode
more knowledge
there's also been work on more efficient
knowledge systems so at nurse there's
now an efficient qa challenge which aims
at building the smallest qa system
and then finally there's been work on
building better knowledge benchmarks
that build on
the benchmarks that we saw today
that's all i have for today and i hope
your final projects are going well